okay everybody joining me right now is
Kerry Condon which I'm so pumped about
she's currently Stacy
ermine trout in better call Saul Carrie
how are you hey you know I'm in Los
Angeles how are you I'm doing good
see now Kerry you're probably shocking
many people right now because if they
watch you in better call Saul they
probably think you have an American
accent and you clearly do not you are
very Irish I hope they think of an
American accent when I'm on the show I'm
not doing my job properly artifice no
and you know I wanted to have you on
Kerry because I became such a big fan of
you I literally first saw you
and we can't fan of you in the walking
dead I am a crazy Walking Dead fan and
you were on a season four premiere 30
days without an accident and you played
Clara and yeah I that was when the show
was really at its peak and I was like
okay who is this sketchy character
that's appearing on the show - Rick in
the middle of the woods and that was you
you were this person and I was like wait
a second is this person someone I could
be sympathetic towards which I felt
because you were this lost woman who had
just lost her husband it seemed like or
were you somebody that was gonna screw
Rick and his gang over how do you get
into a state of mind for that kind of
character you trying to play both ends
to that oh I suppose I was and try I was
only trying to play one end of it which
was like the truth which is that she
really did need his help right and so I
was just plain enough my truth not what
you were seeing how I was being
perceived by the audience like in terms
of Rick was kind of irrelevant to me
okay and it also helps that I hadn't
seen The Walking Dead really so tried it
yeah like I'd only seen the pilot years
when it had come outside only seen it so
I knew he was a lead character but I
didn't really think about you know the
audience being waiting whatever I just
figured I just concentrate on this one
man in the woods
that would look kinda that could help me
so do you think it helped you that you
hadn't watch Walking Dead like prior who
knows who knows yeah I guess I don't I
don't know right I don't know
when you were doing that it must have
been an awesome experience working with
Andrew Lincoln playing Rick because I
think he's one of the best actors I've
seen did you feel like you took anything
from being around him as an actress like
do you feel like you're learning from
the actors and actresses around you of
course you are all the time even if
they're doing stuff that you don't think
is a good idea it's another way of
learning to like how to conduct
ourselves oh he was just such a lovely
guy really he was just a dream to work
with he was so considerate
I'm really respectful when we blocked
the scene at the end you know and she
brings him back to the camp I just about
to go like this called the whole death
scene and everything yeah unlike when we
got to do that all the crew were there
in the director everyone was kind of
standing around and I didn't know what I
was going to do because like it was just
one of those ones orders like I'm just
going to know in the moment like what
I'm going to do right and so I need to
kind of privacy to figure it out with
you and I just quietly asked him would
you would you mind if we could just
block it by ourselves
Wow and he asked the crew he was so nice
he told you that guys we need to like
just have a very space to get their
affairs over but he was really nice to
me he didn't have to do that at all oh
my god that's amazing
yeah it's lovely really nice experience
so he doesn't want him to trust her you
know heard that he has kind face or
something yeah and now on that point
you're making when you get cast for a
role like this you don't get to
previously rehearse this with Angelique
and right like they kind of just throw
you onto set and you're doing it there
right I'm trying to think but I didn't
just to do thank Christ
I didn't have to do the death scene in
my audition right I think I just had to
do I can't sure I can't even remember my
patients talking - oh yes a while ago
pretty sure I did audition first I'm
sure I did
but anyway so yeah I can tell you don't
get to rehearsal on television as fast -
you know there's already half the time
for a lot of that so it's not that I'm
doubted I knew it's just sometimes those
heightened emotions yeah like it is how
we rehearse that I can anyway so I just
[__] do it yeah
exactly so Carrie when I see two is you
have your Irish accent in that role so
whose call is that like when they cast
you do they say hey you know we want you
to keep that Irish thing going or do
they say you know how does that decision
even come about that's a really good
question and that highlights the
importance of casting directors right
the casting directors like don't worry
they don't get nominated in the Oscars I
already know of the role that they play
in like it was this casting director
called Sharon BA leave the Navy casters
are Walking Dead and she knew I was out
and she's known me because I would have
auditioned for her over the year okay
and it was her idea to go well why
couldn't she be from Ireland she could
be flying and a flight from iron it is
much of England right could initially
they wanted an English accent and she
said no just do your Irish accent so
that was really her being just like
super I'm smart yeah yeah okay and nice
and my favour to her yeah and in that
scene - you're talking about with Rick
you know bringing you back to the
campsite and then you find out that your
husband had died but you're still
treating him like you're talking to his
dad hey yeah yes so when you're doing
that is it hard to get invested into
that like okay I'm getting in this
character and I'm believing that I
believe he's still alive here or is
there a point where you're like still
yourself like I'm talking to a head
right now you know what I mean like is
it hard to get into that zone I know
what you're saying because it's such a
surreal circumstantial you know I
totally dancing but I think I just again
just tells us the truth is that I didn't
think if I was the realest life it just
felt like you know when you're very
frail and like it's super like if she'd
obviously been on our own for so long
yeah that like you kind of cling to
something that makes you feel good or
that something about your sense that was
old and I just kind of saw his head and
you know it's being bad that team that
you're just saying to right past or
whatever that's interesting it wasn't
that hard accident it wasn't that hard
for me to be honest
oh that's that is awesome
I could tell I mean you killed it and
like you enjoyed playing that role for
sure that was like one you really
enjoyed it was great I loved it because
the whole it was a beginning middle and
end
that whole episodes like it was like a
little play oh yeah her character sure
and I loved it was very complete like
they began and then they kind of her
relationship evolves they were chatting
going through the woods yeah and then
there was the end so I loved it in that
sense it was very complete Sam it so
easy to sort of plan out how it's going
to do in everything you're right but the
only thing I do in love was that you end
up killing yourself at the end there and
I thought it was such a little character
and I didn't see that coming I was like
whoa like Wow and that's what I want to
ask you you know she hints in the
beginning to him like can you come back
from the things you've done Clara says
to Rick and then when you know she goes
Surak just kill me at the end he's like
why you say you don't get to come back
do you think that's the main reason she
goes I was she couldn't handle maybe her
husband dying or was like things she'd
done like that's what I was always
wondering I think it was just more that
like it was despaired you know like it
went with you know sometimes nothing to
experts and people come in and play with
either intention writers sometimes
people are so down that yeah there's
like something nice in ending isn't it
and in the suit and I think she needed
to think it was all bleak and Ryan
pressing and you don't get to come back
to justify you know to stab like Jesus
it has to be fairly second down yeah
wouldn't you absolutely yeah
what's crazy Carrie is I don't know if
you'll notice his organ watching dead
but your character comes back as a
zombie I think like three episodes if
I'm right that you sneak in the shots a
couple episodes later I can't remember
how many but yet there's a tiny like
she's Balkan or something I stand on top
of them the symbol was a little toy yes
and yes and now I'm wondering when you
played that zombie how long were you in
makeup to put zombie makeup on I was in
there for like ages I can't remember but
Yan's which I was having such a great
time talking to the guy who was do
I'm enjoying watching like how he's
shaving everything and um I didn't liked
walking forward or anything I can't
remember how long it was didn't seem bad
long to me happy hours but you having so
much fun right that's awesome
Kate and I was in say - I feel like with
the walking dead all these characters
could have other spin-offs like I feel
like you could have a spin-off show on
Clara you know like what happened with
your hunter said if there's nothing that
could happen I'm saying over like before
that though we want to know what what
she was talking about what are the
things she's done you know what I mean
like I think you could do that I don't
know oh I think only the die-hard fans
would know what the hell it was go right
do you watch Washington I do did you get
into the show after that or you just
don't have the time like how does that
and then oh I don't you know I go
through phases where I either am reading
a load and not avoiding television
completely and I do that for months on
end and then I get tires in and then I
go back to watching TV so then when I go
back to watching TV I don't also be
documentaries like to get into a show
that's going on that many seasons I'd
have to start back and watch so many
scenes oh yeah Roberts meetings oh god
I'd be watching sure we yeah it's so
much time that that's interesting so you
know it's crazy too because you have the
Irish accent in this one in Walking Dead
character but then in better call Saul I
remember I was watching my mom and you
first appear in episode five and better
call Saul season one and you're just
mysterious woman driving in a car across
from Mike I'm like okay what's up with
this lady but I noticed the face and
then your prominence comes the next
episode which is my favorite episode of
the show five-o you know Mike's back
story so we went reducted to Stacey his
daughter-in-law and you know then we
realized okay she's the mother to Kaylee
and when you started talking I was I had
recognized you walking dead I was like
okay here comes the Irish accent and I
was like whoa whoa that's American
totally flipped a switch and I thought
you did incredible like I forgot you
were an Irish actress and like that was
always going to ask when you're when
you're doing American accents in any
work you've done
where's the motivation like where are
you basing off your American accent
well I suppose first of all I have to
kind of figure out where the person in
it from in America okay you know what I
mean is not different kind is Amit knock
on speak sure experts but there is
different so I learned from somebody a
professional lady dialer coach who told
me I kind of a Midwest accent like sort
of I was doing the job in New Mexico
like Albuquerque and she helps me with
it and the dialogue that was kind of off
those sorts of regions right and then I
did you know there's more like you know
just a general accent just a thing of
general but the general so I just tried
to figure out you know her backstory and
where she's from and start basing the
accent off that okay so when you're
doing that and you're Stacy what you do
amazing I think it's my favorite
character you play my thing is is you do
the mirror accent when the cameras off
are you staying in the American accent
well you see that's the thing normally I
do yes okay
however better call Saul is like I'm not
in every episode sir I think up I go
back and then I have week right I'm not
working I mean I can't be seen in
American accent all those weeks
exhaustion so I don't and then when I go
back to Albuquerque and my god I come on
get it together now
change it over and start doing a bit of
work okay so you're not doing like the
Daniel day-lewis where you stay Stacey
for weeks you when the shows not going
no okay I affected my family would be on
the phone they'd be telling me to knock
it off did they stop talking like that
and you're sound weird that's
interesting okay that's that's very cool
now I wanted to say is I had a
connection to these characters of Stacey
and Clara from Walking Dead where
they're both widows and they both have
that kind of story where we go to that
quote where you can't you come out for
Chianti yeah and she's my favorite scene
in that episode with Mike's backstories
when you and him are well Stacey is
sitting on the couch with Mike and he's
explained her what really went down with
her husband and how he had passed away
when
she's like hinting that Mike basically
killed her husband's partners and then
she's like do you know what happened and
he she knows when she's asking that what
has she figured it out and he's like you
know what happened question is can you
live with it and the face you make after
that is like this like shocking don't
know how to process it and I'm wondering
when you were doing that role of Stacey
did you think at all how you did Clara
where it was like another case of a
widow who's has information they don't
even know how to hold on to in a way no
you know that's funny it's the first
time I've agency pointed out I've ever
realized the comparisons because to be
honest every time I finish your job like
I really have to I almost forget doing
the job just actually completely erase
the whole thing from my mind and start
with a kind of a blank slate again for
the next thing so it's rare that I would
go back on previous characters and try
and find you know familiar sort of a
feeling or a thread or whatever both now
that you say it Jack all right that is
in some kind of connection right yeah
this is a good one yeah yeah yeah that's
right
good but I didn't make the decision with
Daisy in that scene when you said like
her local DNA you know she's processing
it I purposely didn't come to your Rison
that I was trying to convey that she's
processing and she hasn't really come to
a computer sure if she can or like right
going you know what I mean
so I left it open I like that and and I
must have been awesome working with
Jonathan banks you guys had such a good
chemistry like it was such good acting
with you guys that I feel like I forgot
you guys are act after I'm watching a
show you know I feel like I'm there and
yeah yeah and I just wonder like I've
noticed that with all Vince Gilligan's
work the writing is just top notch I
mean when you get this script and you
read it are you getting that feeling
right away like oh my god this is gonna
be good
I do I do for all the other characters
they were not ready for my own God okay
so is is your character Stacy can you
tell me if she's gonna be in season
three yes I'm already started
season three okay perfect and with the
filming of season three do you think you
can live up to seasons one and two they
were so good you know what I only read
one script
okay our season 3 because only of the
episode that I'm in okay and I sort of
play ignorant on the stuff that the
chalk and them alright are you know the
scenes there in truckin and Bob's
character because I watched that then
when the show comes out right like I can
kind of you know experience it like a
viewer or whatever would out know okay
I'm gonna happen or that verb do you
like watching your own work do you watch
it the night arrow is on you know I mean
no no you know what I to be honest with
you like if I'm in Indiana so do I feel
as I'm gonna puke and I you know I
sometimes I have to stop watching the
show friend go like I'll get back to it
eventually because you know I came into
and it just but I want to see for the
other self so locally I'm only in it
like literature otherwise when I've been
in a lead in something in the show it's
rare that I would watch it interesting
okay and then also with Stacy the thing
I saw on message boards talking about
your character for Barisal was that
they're like you know Stacy's not in
Breaking Bad so everyone's worried like
okay if she's not in Breaking Bad I
better call Saul is a prequel what
happens to Stacy as we see Kaylee with
Mike so that's like a big mystery I do
want to see resolve for sure that is
something that people are worried about
you know well I tell you the people who
were worrying about it clearly didn't
watch Breaking Bad correctly oh okay
does featuring it it when if there's
this attitude away watch season or one
episode okay Mike Mike is outside the
house and he waves to Kaylee and her mom
and the mom is kind of fire back in the
dishes it wasn't money no it was a
different person and he references that
it's her mother
Wow oh my god okay that's huge
that is HUGE actually because initially
I was kind of thinking to it like -
Stacy gets shot yeah I know and then it
was Jonathan plays like he was like god
dammit like I referenced you like in
very good
difficut mom and I was like wow I knew
bad
wow that probably just went by me
watching because you're not thinking of
that it's not significant to yet now it
would be now I'd catch it if i rewatch
break about that that's crazy that's Wow
okay yeah I thought something bad
happened I thought she got killed or
something or like sent away I don't know
maybe she get sent away invention
comeback sent away to a lunatic asylum
yeah exactly
now Carrie last I want to talk about it
is awesome that you do Friday the AI for
Iron Man in Avengers age of Ultron and
Captain America Civil War now that is
one you do in the Irish accent I need to
know when they catch you with like okay
where we wanted to the Irish AI voice or
like how did that again how that
decision happened that was initially I
did American English and Irish and in
all three and then they were to decide
which one that they preferred the best
and I'm like and then they went with an
Irish accent so it's like aw Sui that's
gonna be nice yeah both of the years
awesome but actually turned out to be
kind of hard because initially then when
I set when we started recording it you
know they were like don't do it too
strong and I was a casual you don't I'm
not going to distract you know poor
people have some experience forever
obviously like just keep kind of it
somewhat neutral I retire got it and
then as I went down and on there like be
more yourself just say what how would
you say it to say it exactly you say it
I'm thinking are you sure they're gonna
understand me yeah okay so when you're
doing that and they're saying that to
you are you you're in a recording studio
right yeah how does a basis work of
course you have to play around with
Direction you know go for them even if
you and then sometimes when the volcano
take it back and maybe say a player say
it that way like you have to be very
flexible and play around with it and
then they can decide at the end which
you know options that they want to use
so it's kind of liberating in the way
you just kind of offer up a load of
ideas and a toothpick so when you're
talking to Iron Man or Robert Angiers
character Tony Stark is he recording his
lines first or are you are you hearing
his lines when you're saying them
yeah he's alright he recorded his
because I get to watch the picture you
know when I write it on the screen like
where my voice is coming in at walk
point in the movie your awesome is that
too
and carry I did want to ask you I've
seen your Instagram that you are a pet
lover and I want to ask you if you have
any pets and what they do
I know pipes I won't have a big farm you
know okay and now the cable dog Jack
Ross so and I have two horses two horses
that and now yes you ride the horses or
you just have them as like you know no I
write them one of them I adopted him
from I did a TV show about horse race in
Mansfield called look and when I
finished that job I adopted one of the
horses that worked on the job buddy
that's incredible yeah he's so cute now
I'm like God you so cute you have these
horses in the States or in Ireland like
where do you know they're in the States
yeah I write them and I'm at work and I
take care of them I love the chores and
a whole lot of nurturing animals but
lovers
that's amazing lovely thing to do with
your free time you know that is the life
carrot I impressed I wish I had horses
but I'm in cold New York right now and
I'm actually recording this podcast in
my basement it's freezing in here right
now but uh I'm jealous that you're
anyway no radium I suppose it's November
it's bad good if it's cold right like
yeah true what it's supposed to be yeah
you're right
as we wrap this up are there any words
of inspiration you would give to any
aspiring female actresses in this
specific industry or now because there
is so much media out there and it seems
more competitive to me from looking the
outside Dee do you feel that way like
what would you say to maybe a female
actress upcoming that's getting
discouraged like with the industry okay
when I suppose it depends a more type of
actress I'm talking to like if you want
to be an actress because like you just
want to act and you wants to play there
are two different people and all the
sort of discipline and work that comes
with this
there's one you know advice and then if
you're just interested in basically
being famous and making lots of money
there's obviously different advice so I
would suppose you could sort of identify
your motivation behind why you want
being an actress
mmm maybe that's probably the first
thing you should do in case it's rooted
in something that's probably not good
for you or something and then what
others like so it gives um I suppose I'd
say if you're prepared to be extremely
lonely for most of your life yeah go
ahead is it alright alright there we go
so that's really funny um yeah I can say
the two headed Taniya in your head sure
it's all in your head and like you know
there's a lot of traveling involved yeah
constantly away from home yeah and
you're worried you know what I mean even
if you're away from when you live away
from your parents anyways there's always
like this associated from your familiar
surroundings so that's quite gets cool
all the time and then you know you have
to be there's their periods when you're
not working where you know it's hard to
mentally stay like okay and not get
bitter or jealous certain people or you
know become a sort of a negative person
so there's all sorts of challenges and
that's not even talking about the actual
do enough yeah right waiting around
right that's just all on the outside
yeah that is that's a wild way to look I
that's awesome perspective yeah and I
was gonna ask what you like to be an
actor I have tried the background acting
gig before and it was cool and stuff but
I got discouraged I have to say I
started you know I went into radio
because like I thought I don't know if I
can do the acting there's some people do
it there's some people doing radio too
but like I think I just got discouraged
honestly cuz like a lot of people you
tried do anything that's like in the
entertainment street I feel like talked
you down you don't I mean like they're
like oh that's not a real job or this
and that and it's like I think you got
to my head you know
oh really yeah but I don't like people
to discourage no I don't think that's
very nice because like everyone
discouraged me for being enough
sure sure try let's have listen to them
but I love the radio I think goal for
the radio I know radio programs in the
hotel talk radio it's great oh thank you
I appreciate that yeah and I'm trying to
like transfer now to YouTube and like I
want to do stuff like that like this is
your the first big interview on this
show Stevie TV and I'm excited about it
I'm so happy you came on it's so nice of
you to do this I'm a huge fan of yours
thank you this is like a dream come true
for me and I'm Canadian yes and I wanted
to know if there's anything you wanted
to promote or anything you're currently
working on that we can plug for you when
I'd better call South Seas and trees
when I'm working on Dennis there's a
cinnamon Cortland but if you can't even
count that next by the time it comes out
it's going to be year everyone's
attention span is like what three
minutes yeah are you exactly
thanks though
Kerry thank you so much for joining me
and I'd love to have you on again okay
take care last enough